[Musique]
bonjour philippe petit bonjour - le
président de l'udps et martinique le diy
l'union des démocrates et indépendants
philippe petit la guyane s'est invitée
dans le débat présidentiel à plusieurs
niveaux on y reviendra quelque part
n'est ce pas quand même désolant qu'on
en soit un tel niveau de désoeuvrement
pour ce territoire français d'amérique
du sud
alors c'est un débordement français et
c'est le plus grand débordement français
qui fait 86 mille kilomètres carrés avec
des frontière extrêmement poreuse entre
le chine et le brésil qui fait qu'il ya
une insécurité chronique qu'on ne peut
pas balayer d'un coup de baguette
magique
opale non plus dupe et les gens avec la
forêt amazonienne
par conséquent il est extrêmement
difficile de pouvoir gérer ce
débordement qui te continent distinctes
donc de nous il dans la culture ce qui a
deux qu'on avait fait à l'époque je
crois que c'était l'arrêt de villers
cotterêts et ensuite l'abbé grégoire
pour la martinique pour toutes les
populations de france est en avance
était de mettre la langue française en
avant pour que toutes ces communautés
puissent dialoguer parce qu'il ya déjà
un problème de barrière de la langue
et quand vous ne respectez pas ou quand
vous ne connaissez pas la langue
vous ne pouvez pas comprendre certaines
subtilités qui sont ils et à
l'administration française
oui mais les archives sonores de france
fo par exemple ont ressorti ce matin des
déclarations de de guyanais qui dans les
années 70 se plaignaient déjà de cette
situation on se souvient philippe petit
qu'en 2008
la dualité a déjà soulevé contre ce
manque de considération
ce manque de considération de la part de
l'état français vis-à-vis de cayenne les
choses ne bougent pas ou trop peu
alors je le redis un pays qui bouge du
brésil avec des cultures différentes et
tenter par effectivement d'autres
cultures il faut savoir s'ils ont vu le
lycée français et si on veut le lycée
français il faut effectivement donné les
moyens supplémentaires sachant qu' un
atout qui est la fusée d'un alien avec
une séquence marielle je censure mais de
la sonatel je suis dégoûté de la france
non je parle du côté de la france
l'atout que représente la fusée ariane
pour pouvoir rester dans le continent
sud américain
j'ai aussi ils disent tout simplement
que courroux permet de balancer des
satellites de télécommunications pour
que la france s à 4 j alors qu'en fois
en guyane il n'y a pas de réseau à
l'enseigné ce que je dis donc la
manifestation du coup légitimes des
guyanais pour a fait en sorte que la
france puisse grâce à la richesse
qu'elle tire de la base spatiale de ou
et tout l'intérêt économique et
géopolitique stratégique est là le
ferrand sont effectivement il ya la 4g
pente ou en guyane mais je crois que
avant tout et on parle de la notion de
culture et la notion de langue il faut
que vous ayez un universalisme qu'ils
puissent être français qu'ils puissent
parler aux gens et qu'ils puissent faire
que les différentes communautés soient
sous la même administration comprennent
les mécanismes d'une administration le
jour il ya des considérations je le
redis paris ne s'est pas fait en un jour
donc au mien on décrète que la guyane
seront jouées indépendante parce que les
poches du brésil et à ce moment là on
laisse aller
ou bien effectivement et c'est là qu'on
va voir ce que fait la france puisque
monsieur 15,9 et madame barrettes sont
décidés de prendre l'avion et devenir
enfin en tout cas je sais pas cazeneuve
mais au moins une délégation
interministérielle deux ministres qui va
venir
on verra donc tout l'intérêt que
quelques la france porte à la guyane et
à ce moment là je ne doute pas que le
problème sera résolu parce que je crois
quand même que les guyanais ont tout
intérêt à rester à mon sens avec la
france plutôt qu'avec le brésil non on
voit en ce moment à travers la
corruption et à travers l'effondrement
économique qui a plus intérêt à rester
avec un pays européen
à la date d'aujourd'hui pensez vous que
cette ce mécontentement social sociétal
puisse s'étendre en martinique et en
guadeloupe à n'importe quel moment
nous avons affaire que nous sommes
insulaires et que nous n'avons pas le
problème de porosité des frontières nous
n'avons pas le problème d'immigration
intense comme on vit en guyane mais nous
souffrons effectivement notamment quand
vous avez des petites retraites et que
vous avez une vie qui correspond à 10
ans en tout cas au moins avec ou sans
être 20% plus cher
au niveau de l'alimentation il ya une
logique de contagion qui peut s'exprimer
à n'importe quel moment
d'autant plus que les élections
présidentielles sont souvent propices
aux tous les ressentiments toutes les
frustrations quand on voit au sommet
lolita les certains candidats et que ça
pose une certaine difficulté de
compréhension tout à fait légitime vos
fils et petits vous êtes affilié à une
formation nationale vous constatez ce
manque de considération de la part des
instances de votre parti lorsque vous
voyez que ce qui s'est passé en 6 68 à
ce qui s'est passé hier aux antilles en
surtout lorsqu'on parle de ce manque de
considération de la france de l'état
français des institutions françaises
vis-à-vis de nos pays dans votre parti
comment vous sentez vous ressentez les
choses nous a l'impression qu'on entend
ce que nous sommes ce que nous disons je
réponds sur deux plans le plan général
et le plan du parti le plan général pour
que les courses se fassent entendre
ils ont leur culture avec des bombes en
guyane il ya des 500 frères avec des
cagots donc chaque département ultra
marin ou en tout cas insulaire a sa
spécificité pour se faire entendre
ça veut dire qu'effectivement il ya un
problème chronique avec la france où on
doit montrer l'intérêt d'avoir par
exemple une zone économique exclusive
qui fait que autour de la vente inégaux
tour de tous les territoires d'outre-mer
vous avez la deuxième puissance mondiale
donc il y aura toujours à démontrer au
niveau du banc tic dont je suis le
président lui dit je n'ai rien à
rajouter vous n'avez qu'à regarder les
il ya quatre circonscriptions la
martinique il ya un débat national
contre lui 10 et les républicains qui le
réserve soixante dix circonscriptions
gagnables
on ne parle même pas de gagnable ici où
les indépendantistes et la gauche
traditionnellement sont en tête
eh bien on n'a pas été capable alors à
la menthe inc je n'ai pas de dialogue
avec ces messieurs dames des
républicains depuis deux ans donc ça
c'était même pas la peine d'en parler
parce qu'il ya une certaine
condescendance mais que au point où
point de vue national je pensais très
sincèrement que lui dire où est acté que
il suffisait qu'on ait une
circonscription quelle qu'elle soit on
débattait par lula à ses conceptions la
moins gagnable mais au moins que lui d y
soit représentée en tant que parti
centriste qui est associé aux
républicains
ça n'a pas été le cas ces déceptions
rider république siens mardi
je dénonce deux choses le mépris des
républicains en tunique et deuxièmement
le l'innocuité de l'udi qui n'a pas peur
nous allâmes anti n'est fait même si
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le bilan
lagarde ici là qu'après soit vous êtes
militant
vous restez soit vous n'êtes pas
militant vous démissionner parce que
vous dites
il ne nous considère je suis militant je
suis militant je suis vestiaires ludique
donc j'assume la mission que j'ai et
j'espère pouvoir quand même essayer
d'appréhender le sait la tronche mais
vous restez quand même pour le moment où
il y à des élections qui arrivent je
suis été réélu en 2016 prise d'un de lui
dit je ne pas laisser le bateau comme
d'autres personnes laissent le bateau
dans les trahisons qui dans tous les
états majors que je vois bien que par la
malaisie
il n'y a pas que les trahisons lire
aussi le très chic ne très faibles
chiffres que vous avez obtenus lors des
élections pour la septième en décembre
2015 quelque part ce matin ça n'a pas
démoralisé des troupes ou bien alors
changer le regard qu'on pourrait avoir
sur votre formation ici localement alors
je vais vous dire le centre n'a jamais
été implantée la martinique donc c'était
un pari effectivement assez particulier
et soit vous décidez que le centre ne
sera jamais implanté donc ne voit pas du
délire jouera jamais des centristes
unique soit vous hisse vous espérez que
c'est la voix de la raison la voie de la
sagesse la voie de la réflexion la voie
de la volonté et à ce moment là vous
vous continuez
en attendant que des jeunes prennent la
succession la voie de la sagesse pour
vous c'est d'y aller pour lors des
prochaines législatives
oui c'est d'y aller sinon c'est pas la
peine de faire l'idée ici lors compte de
débat national avec une formation
nationale vous n'allez pas je ne vois
pas à quoi ça sert alors à ce moment il
fallait me restait dans une formation
régionale
il s'occupait seulement des problèmes
régionaux alors semble être sûr de votre
participation à cette élection
législative il ya quatre
circonscriptions et pour les trois
autres circonscriptions ce serait qui se
serait quoi alors il ya je suis dans le
sud a priori puisque ça avait été déjà
au départ acté par lui qui m'a investi
de manière régionale de manière
nationale
je ne pensais pas honnêtement que on
n'aurait pas eu une circonscription et
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas cherché sur
les trois autres circonscriptions
aujourd'hui donc j'ai deux propositions
soient ou 3 3 possibilités on reste là
tout simplement parce qu'on était déjà
sur le sud mais je ne vais pas me résous
soit donc on aura et des femmes on est
en pourparlers avec un certain nombre de
femmes valable pour pouvoir justement
qu'attendez vous barrent valable c'est à
dire qu'ils connaissent la compétence
politique c'est pas tout le monde qui a
la compétence politique
et puis que surtout qu'ils ont envie
c'est à dire dans le dans leur idéal
même qu'ils ont envie vous savez que ce
n'est pas toujours facile en politique
vous voyez le nombre de le parlementaire
qui à l'assemblée nationale femme ce
n'est pas évident ou bien deuxième
possibilité nous avons un jeune
mouvement qui nous a approchés qui est
sympathique et qui a le mérite d'avoir
des jeunes à l'intérieur et qui
souhaiteraient qu'on s'associe et qui
partagent une certaine idée une idée
centristes et qui a déjà des candidats
donc on pourrait envisager la mène
environnement sap et cette forme si vous
demandez vous vous le devinez vous êtes
à ses fins politiques voire non
soumettre cette édition non jeu ce sont
vous savez alors prêt en porte voix
suave et soit vous avez des formations
extrémistes donc vous chercherez les
formations extrémistes soit vous avez
des formations modérées dons qui peuvent
se mettre compatible avec le centriste
je vois que vous êtes intrigué je veux
lire et le moment cette formation a déjà
annoncé un candidat dans le sud
oui l'a déjà annoncé aux candidats dans
le sud donc il sur le prénom sur un
certain steve je crois que vous ne voyez
le voyez d oz non pas lui serve
démocratique de la marque par exemple
qui nous a fait une proposition tout à
fait honnête de dire bon et bien on
s'associe et à la limite on on trouve
une autre circonscription s'il le faut
bon le sud est cité par exemple c'est
tout à fait honnête de l'otan ce sont
des jeunes engagés et qui sont
effectivement eu dans le concept de
nation française donc on peut par
exemple discuter avec eux tout à fait de
l'est pas dit que ça se fera mais je
veux dire que l'essentiel bon - c'est
que lui dit
à travers cette association s'il le faut
soit représenté et ce sera votre dernier
combat alors dans la vie j'ai appris
qu'il ne faut dire jamais
quand il s'agit de choses sérieuses au
niveau législatif ou pensez bien que j
60 ans les panneaux présentent à 65 ans
si je ne suis pas élu soyons clair mais
je n'ai pas dit que forcément c'est le
dernier combat louga législatif
je ne me représenterai pas à un certain
âge je n'ai pas là la force physique de
certains qui préside un qui décoiffe
tous merci beaucoup
puis les petits président de l'udac
martinique merci d'avoir avec nous ce
matin bonne journée
[Musique]